So it's important for you to recognize
that DNA never leaves the nucleus. It never
comes in direct contact with the machinery necessary
to build protiens, called roibosomes. And as a
solution of this problem there's an intermediate step
that involves a chemical cousin of DNA called
RNA. So although DNA never leaves the nucleus A copy is made, and this copy is
composed of a very closely related molecule called RNA. It's
kind of like taking a, a big book of recipes,
or our big genome book here, and we're just xeroxing
a few pages that we're interested in, that'll help us
make the protein we need. Obviously, we don't need the
whole genome to make one protein. But there are sequences
of information that are necessary to make up individual proteins,
and we just want to make copies of what we need, and
bring them out to the cytoplasm to read.
This copying process must happen for every protein-coding gene.
Any gene is going to produce a protein, including
the ABO gene. So for the ABO gene to
be turned into protein, we'll first make a
copy that'll be brought to the cytoplasm, and then
turned into protein. This basic process of making copies
of DNA, bringing it to the cytoplasm to make
protein, is so important to almost all lifeforms on
our planet, that we call it the Central Dogma. And
the Central Dogma takes on a very specific form
in these three words, organized in a certain order. They're
found up here, I just want to see if you
can plug them into the boxes in the right order.
Blank to blank to blank is the Central Dogma. See
if you can figure out what belongs in each one.